ever since the gold rush started in 1848
california has been the land of dreams
whether you were an immigrant looking
for a better life or an aspiring
entrepreneur that wanted to hit it big
your best shot was in california over
time this led to california housing some
of the biggest companies in the world
from wells fargo and disney to apple
into google and consequently we also saw
the wealthiest people in the world
reside in fancy mansions across
california
eventually california's economy became
so large that it started dwarfing
countries right now california's gdp
stands at 3.356 trillion dollars this
makes california the fifth largest
economy in the world
but despite this title it hasn't been
nearly that great for most californian
citizens for quite some time
in fact most californians are struggling
to make ends meet due to the rapidly
going wealth inequality in the state
things have gotten so bad that
california actually became the state
with the highest poverty level in the us
this isn't to say that californians
aren't making money per se but rather
that the cost of living in the state is
so high that even decent income earners
fall below the poverty line according to
u.s census bureau a whopping 15.4
percent of californians are living in
poverty and i'm sure there's loads of
people that are just above the poverty
line that don't have it much better so
what happened to the golden state
with sky-high inflation and rapidly
rising prices across the country we've
started to hear this phrase more and
more you will own nothing and be happy
while this may sound a bit cynical and
pessimistic this is exactly what's been
happening in california for decades
californians have slowly been priced out
of one thing after another which has
forced them to rent or give up the sad
item likely the best example of this is
housing much of the us has seen a
significant rise in housing prices ever
since the pandemic started this has led
many to hope for a housing market crash
so that they can finally buy for a
reasonable price but even if there was a
housing crash it wouldn't be much easier
for californians to buy a house here's
the thing the median sale price across
the entire state is a whopping at 843
000
even if the housing market were to crash
30 percent the median sale price would
stand at 600 thousand dollars which is
still higher than the median sale price
before the pandemic started the median
household income in california currently
stands at 78 000
this means that the average house costs
over 10 times the average family's
annual income and even with the 30 crash
the average house would cost about seven
and a half times the average income this
has made homeownership completely
unattainable for the average californian
family and if you're a single person you
probably wouldn't even consider a house
to make things worse and it's not like
things are much better for renters for
families renting a three-bedroom house
will on average cost them three thousand
dollars per month or 36 000 per year
that's literally higher than the median
personal income in the us in 2020
and it's not just housing that's crazy
expensive either basically every facet
of daily life is significantly more
expensive take gym memberships for
example the national average for a gym
membership is 58
meanwhile the average gym membership in
l.a is 70
similarly in california the average
haircut for a woman is 69 dollars and
the average haircut for a man is 45
dollars the national average is 44
dollars for women and 28 dollars for men
these insane californian prices carry
over to clothing as well
the average pair of jeans cost 60 in
california while the national average is
nearly half of that at 34
and i don't even think we need to
discuss gas prices which currently
stands at over six dollars per gallon
aside from getting screwed over from a
cost of living perspective many
californians also get screwed over from
a tax perspective as well it's no secret
that california has some hefty state
income taxes which range from one
percent to twelve point three percent by
the time the average californian pays
their taxes and daily living expenses
they're left with virtually no money
this is why living paycheck to paycheck
is extremely common in california in
fact the only state in which it's even
more common is hawaii considering this
it's basically impossible for the
average californian to build any sort of
wealth so it's quite ironic that most
people are only now complaining that
they are forced to owe nothing and to be
happy californians have already been
experiencing this for decades
aside from barely making ends meet right
now california is also supposed to run
into an opportunity crisis within the
coming decades here's the thing droves
of the companies and individuals are
ditching california tesla and oracle for
example have outright moved their
headquarters from california to texas
meanwhile other companies haven't quite
moved their headquarters but they're
investing significant amounts of money
outside california apple for instance
recently built a 1 billion campus in
austin historically this was something
that companies were extremely reluctant
to do because california simply had the
best talent and the most motivated
people in the country but this is no
longer true for starters the rest of the
country has caught up significantly
thanks to the opportunities created by
technology and secondly many of the
talented engineers and white collar
workers in california have been playing
the state themselves so companies are no
longer limited to recruiting primarily
from california aside from being able to
recruit more diverse talent companies
are also able to significantly reduce
their payroll by moving to lower cost
states you see given the insane living
expenses in california companies also
have to pay insane salaries to hire the
best talent at facebook for example
software engineers earn a minimum of 184
000 and up to 1.61 million dollars this
is the same case with google and every
other mega cab company as well by moving
to states like idaho and texas however
these same companies can get away with
paying 20 30 less for the same jobs at
first glance it might sound like these
companies are taking advantage of tech
workers from these states by paying them
less but this isn't the case either you
see these discounted salaries stretch
further in these low cost states than
the full salaries do it in california so
it's a win-win scenario
employees earn relatively more what
companies pay less on top of this many
of these states are offering companies
loads of incentives to move there for
example texas offered tesla up to an 80
property tax rebate for 10 years if they
moved to texas so it makes more sense
than ever for these companies to leave
california and as more of them make the
choice to move we're slowly going to see
opportunity leaving the state which will
just make it even harder for
californians
on top of high living expenses and
fleeing world something else that has
been heavily weighing down on california
is the ease of being homeless now i'm
not trying to say that being homeless is
easy because it's obviously not but with
that being said california has the least
severe consequences for being homeless
they have loads of generous homeless
programs and they even hand out money to
homeless people this man in san
francisco for example is earning 620 per
month by just living on the streets
of course this is not enough money to
live a royal life but it's also more
than enough money to buy food and basic
necessities now many people describe
this as a benefit and it somewhat is
while many californians aren't exactly
swimming in wealth they never have to
worry about starving either
worst case scenario they can live on the
streets on checks from the government
but at the same time this is also kind
of negative as well
if you're able to carry on daily life by
doing nothing a good amount of people
will choose to do nothing for example
take a listen to what this homeless man
thinks i mean if we're gonna be
realistic they pay you to be homeless
here when you said that san francisco
pays people to be homeless what did you
mean by that
you mean that literally yeah
i mean i get 620 bucks a month dude
from general assistance or would you how
was that hard to get
phone call bro
[ __ ] phone call 200 food stamps and
620 bucks cash a month wow forget about
it why wouldn't i do it and he's not the
only one who thinks like this
california's homeless programs are so
generous that homeless people from other
states immigrate to california to be
homeless there instead somehow
california has transitioned from being
the dream destination for entrepreneurs
to being the deepest nation for the
homeless not only does this drain the
resources of california but it also
makes everyday life for californians way
harder due to the large number of
homeless people it's common to find
human feces and drug needles across
their cities in fact this issue has
become so prevalent that san francisco
pays people 184 thousand dollars per
year to clean their sidewalks when you
have to do this you clearly have a
problem and i don't know about you but i
wouldn't want to go to work or have my
kids go to school in such an area
leaving the state is often the top
priority for anyone with any sort of
financial stability and as these middle
class upper middle class and high income
families leave the state the state is
simply driven further into the depths of
poverty
[Music]
given the circumstances in california i
don't think you'd be surprised here that
the population is on the decline but
it's not as drastic as you might think
and this brings up the question why do
people choose to stay in california
despite all these drawbacks well there's
a few reasons for this starting with
wealth bubbles most of the celebrities
and billionaires live in california live
in an extremely nice portion of the
state that is filled with other wealthy
individuals so they're essentially able
to avoid all of the poverty and despair
that average californians face on a
daily basis but what about the average
californian why do they choose to stay
well usually the top answer is some sort
of emotional connection to the state
maybe it they were born and raised in
california and their entire family lives
there
or maybe the person is heavily involved
with outdoor activities and good weather
along with beautiful nature are top
priorities aside from some sort of
emotional connection with the state many
people choose to stay in california or
even move to california in order to
minimize discrimination california is by
far the most accepting place in the
entire world whether we're talking about
people of color or lgbt so people that
are part of these communities are
reluctant to leave for obvious reasons
it should also be mentioned that
california is a sanctuary state which
means that they have some of the loosest
rules when it comes to illegal
immigrants in fact california is home to
over 2 million unauthorized immigrants
and i don't think these guys have any
plans of moving out anytime soon also
something else to note is that there's
loads of californians who do want to
leave but their circumstances prevent it
for example they might have a unique job
that's only available in california or
maybe they don't have enough money to
take the risk of completely uprooting
their lives and moving to another state
but even with all these driving factors
california's population is still
declining so clearly the motivation to
leave is quite strong for many at the
end of the day california is by no means
perfect they have an extremely high cost
of living high taxes a massive homeless
problem and companies are fleeing as
fast as possible all of these factors
have led to california becoming the poor
state in america and from an objective
perspective it makes a little sense to
stay
but for many this is not the only
consideration for them california is
their home and though it may not be
perfect they would rather stick with
california and try to fix the state than
flee and watch the state rod from afar
would you guys stay in california
comment that down below
also drop a like if you hope that
california can make a recovery for the
sake of its people and of course
consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]